[Music]
lisa is with us in chicago hi lisa how
are you
how you doing good how can we help
so i'm in the middle of negotiating my
salary for a new job
and i'm a little bit
i don't know how to handle it or how to
take it from here and
to give you a little bit of background
uh i'm in a dead-end i.t job
so i decided to go somewhere else plus
get a certification
so my next job i asked for
i currently make 73 base
i ask for 83
but they're not willing to pay more than
75.
so
how big a company is this
it's big
big
yes financial uh during the financial
industry okay all right
well you probably got your number you
just need to decide if you want to work
there i doubt that they're going to do a
bunch of negotiating i think they've
told you what they're going to do you
might get a little bit out of this but
uh
the the the way to posture and position
yourself so you don't harm yourself into
a brand new job you don't automatically
end the honeymoon before it starts
um is just switch shoes for a minute
if you were that supervisor that's
interviewing you
or that company that's interviewing you
why would you give you more money i want
it is not a reason
okay and i had a magic number in my head
that they didn't meet doesn't make them
a bad person
i was the worst i would have a magic
number in my head and it was so
sometimes it was ludicrous and then the
boss would come in and i'd feel like
they and offer me hey here's a job
and here's 5 000 less than your magic
number and i would feel that as a loss
like they had taken something from me
right they had it all right yeah they'd
offered me a job and so you just have to
decide do i want to
um change my life for 2 000 bucks and a
big company that if you go in there and
bust it and do great work and provide
value
will increase your salary over time in
in different roles and professional and
professional responsibilities right so
the way i would approach it is i would
just ask the hiring supervisor that
you're talking to or whatever the phrase
is that you use
how could i add more value
in this position that would make me more
valuable
that would make you guys want to pay me
more
i don't want you to give me more money
just because i i think i deserve it
because i breathe air i'm willing to do
things that are moral and reasonable
extra
i'm willing to
add
elements to this that that you know that
make me more valuable to this company
and then you that you know what what
would be the thing i would need to will
you need to get this certification great
can we agree that when i get this
certification then i that it comes with
an automatic raise that matches that and
i'll go get the certification and you
can start at the lower position and then
go get the certification six months
later and get your raise right
um or whatever but but you're asking
you're not asking them to give you
something because you're entitled in any
way no i'm not i don't feel that way at
all i know and so make sure you're
vocalizing it that way
how can i how can i add value
that because i would really like to make
80 but i don't expect you to pay me that
or 85 i don't expect you to pay me that
unless there's a reason
and so i'm asking you
what would i need to do to be worth 85
or 80 or whatever for you guys because
i'd really like to get there help me
because i'm all about personal growth
i'm all about getting better and i'm all
about making sure that i make you more
than i cost you
okay well thank you i appreciate it sure
and i think
dave you that that wisdom is good
because she enters into a conversation
that's with not against and she might
find out oh man we pay this this is a
big company and so we pay this band of
employee x and y and you're at the top
of that range but we're going to move
you so you find out actually they're
capping the value
that they can but so you find out a lot
of stuff when it's we're on the same
side but when we're across the
negotiating table then it's got to be
you versus me right
well a negotiation properly done of any
kind
is not put up your dukes that's right
it's not
i'm gonna take from you
so that i get more right it's not a
zero-sum game
uh in other words if she brought in an
extra million dollars in revenue to that
organization would they gladly give her
more money absolutely in a heartbeat
you know
most of them would anyway some of them
are too stupid to do that but most of
them
most companies small large anything and
so it's like we go win together i tell
folks around here if you leave the cave
kill something and drag it home i will
share it with you right you know i'm not
going i'm not greedy i don't but but
also not gonna pay you you know and one
guy go well you know you need to pay me
this because i've got all these degrees
and i'm like he had more degrees than a
thermometer i mean it was like and i'm
like dude your race is effective when
you are right you know this is a small
business so at so all negotiations are
how can we get to where we want to be
together if you're buying something from
somebody how do you keep
i once once i sit across table from
somebody my hackles come up yeah how do
you keep from turning it into a
competition yeah
well
the problem is
oh yeah if
my deal becomes not beating him my deal
become my win is when i get the deal
done okay
not did i destroy him
not that i got him to take five thousand
dollars less but no we should get the
deal done because
see
if you get into a one-dimensional thing
on a negotiation where it's just like a
price on you're buying a car from
somebody the price is this and you go
okay
well i'll give you this well i'll take
that
well back and you go you know it's just
back and forth to you meets and then you
go we'll split the difference or
whatever and you go back and forth with
this verbal ping pong back it balls on
your side and it balls on my side and
every time we get a little bit closer
finally someone goes enough this is it
that you've reached my point you got my
number and you go okay i'm in or i'm not
or
but if you can make it about something
else yeah you know it's not just
the price okay for instance i'm used to
you know buy a lot of foreclosures or
buy a lot of real estate and i would
tell people in those days a house has
been sitting on the market for a while
we will close it this afternoon for cash
now that matters
yes you lighten their load a little bit
this is just we're done you got money
tonight
to go buy a lobster dinner baby i mean
this is today you've been screwing
around with this house for six months
you're behind on your payments tonight
and in return what do i get price a good
house yeah yeah i get a how but i get it
i get a good price but but the immediacy
is a different factor than price right
and so you add other factors into the
equation when you're negotiating and in
her case the factor we're adding in is
how can i add value
to where you wish
that i was here you're happy
that i'm here what can i do to be the
best team player you've ever had on the
team yeah you know and and what does it
look like to be as our friend pat
lincione says the ideal team player